[Applause]
look at that how beautiful that set
looks oh my goodness happy thursday
everyone it's my second favorite day
after spa day
i love giving couples massages
in my van
hey let's roll lenexio
greg's philosophical monologue of the
week
because the news is really boring right
now and he had to come up with something
[Music]
tonight's monologue
evil
yeah an uplifting topic right
well it was either evil or this
you're the guy who said gonorrhea was no
worse than a cold
well i'll bet you never had a cold that
felt just like that did you i must have
got it on a toilet seat doc
now that's a hell of a place to take a
girl
[Laughter]
man i love that
yeah i'll take evil now evil obviously
exists but does calling people evil help
you win an argument or is it like me
after three aperol spritzes it's just
too easy
and really when someone does something
awful just saying it's evil won't stop
it i mean the view is in its 25th year
[Laughter]
i kid they aren't evil they're just
wrong
so what is evil well communists are evil
fascists are evil
cats are evil
especially that one
through that into a walk
but when you get in a debate about stuff
such evil branding sucks the left will
often call you evil to end conversation
which is why i'm glad when geraldo does
it
because it ends in conversation
but they'll often call you something
worse like racist so it's no wonder
governor desantis said no to doing the
view after they asked and after a past
year where they've smeared him like one
of joy behar's eight morning bagels
they've thrown more shade his way than
stelter does sitting on a snow globe
just visualize it
but how can you be civil with people
like this
you're just short of calling him a
negligent homicidal sociopath because
that's what he is he's risking the lives
of children children's parents their
their grandparents anyone they may come
in contact with so that he could appeal
to his white supremacist base jeff said
santa's i i think he's a fascist and a
bigot it's anti-black it's anti-gay it's
anti-lgbtq plus it's anti-american and
it started with crt if you start coming
after black people what comes next right
of course the lgbtq house community and
then women and then other marginalized
groups
my soul is bleeding
so basically desantis is a racist sexist
transphobic homophobe in other words
evil and once you're evil who needs
conversation it eliminates dialogue
meaning all that's left is aggression
you know i was guilty of this once i'm
pretty sure i called pelosi evil
and not to her face
or at least her most recent face
terrible and i'm sure i called this
block of wood evil
when really he's not he's just dumb as a
block of wood
who else is evil well the person who
invented double stuffed oreos that's for
sure and the guy at the gym who filled
my speedo with nair
now i have to do my pole dancing in
jeans
why did i sign up for those classes and
people they've called me evil too which
is hard to believe i'm so lovable it
hurts at least for seven to ten days and
then it goes away
but i certainly don't think i'm evil so
it stands to reason the people i call
evil don't consider themselves evil
either i mean if you asked lucifer
himself if he was evil he'd probably be
like hey i'm no day at the beach but i'm
no joy reid either
so liberals aren't evil even if they
think we are it's the key difference
that charles krauthammer noted first we
think they're wrong they think we're
evil it's something to remember when
you're trying to persuade people you
know as russia invaded ukraine we call
putin evil but does he think he's evil
no he just thinks he's working on behalf
of mother russia and he'll kill anyone
to do it hell he violated international
law and those shirtless horseback photos
were a crime against humanity
is george soros evil maybe maybe not but
really what if he's just dumb i mean
does this guy really think more murders
is a good thing maybe he's just a
psychopath like so many corporate heads
not ours though they're the best
please give my puppy back
but the idea that he's a batman villain
makes it easier to categorize him the
he's evil argument saves a buttload of
time and energy mass shooters oh they're
they are evil but that's just the first
step in that problem what made them evil
drugs isolation mental illness a culture
that applauds violence media coverage
brian kilmeade's last book
the point calling someone evil can be
accurate but it blunts efforts to figure
out what comes next for that you need
strategic empathy you need to ask why
something happened but temporarily
exclude yourself from saying because
they're evil why did putin invade
ukraine why does soros fund idiotic
prosecutors who ruin our lives why does
a sick fiend kill dozens of children if
we knew why putin invaded well we did
know he warned us a bunch kind of the
way china is warning us now and now
brittany griner just got nine years for
pot joe biden is demanding that russia
set her free but how do you call putin
up to have that conversation after
you've already labeled him an evil war
criminal
language paints us into corners george
soros claims he's all about criminal
justice and he may believe it which
means he's not evil he's just stupid
really stupid like joy behar stupid if
that's possible
but calling him evil misses what's
really going on which is he has no idea
what's going on he's more insulated from
the real world than a kardashian
with way worse pictures of his butt
you don't want to look at that
fact is stupid people could be effective
at certain things good or evil mass
shooters if you call the scum evil
you're right but you got to look closer
you'd find the incentive is infamy if i
kill more than the last guy i live
forever it's like trying to outscore
another video gamer they're competing
against on their laptop once you see
that you see the solution a media
blackout we can cover what happened
without making each perp famous
so while evil exists it's often times a
fact that you should put aside if you
need to solve an intractable problem but
of course that suggestion goes out the
window if the person is absolutely truly
evil and there's nothing you could do
about it i'm sure you'll know that when
you see it
[Applause]
welcome tonight's guests
he's the last thing terrorists see
before they turn off the tv former cia
operative and host of black files
declassified on discovery science
channel mike baker
and the way this gentleman talks do you
think he's from a foreign country actor
greg ellis
and she returned her skinny jeans for
being too roomy foxy's contributor cat
tip
[Applause]
and he calls the atlantic the shallow
end my massive sidekick in the nwa world
television champion tyrone
mike baker i think he would be an expert
on evil right uh i know it when i see it
yeah so you know it when you see it's
just like porn um
well yeah
you are a cia agent so you're always
fighting what we believe to be is evil
um do you believe in strategic empathy
the idea of you have to set that aside
and actually look at what their
interests and intentions are
well yeah yeah you've got to understand
plans and intentions and motivations
right um in order to to
whatever you're doing whether it's you
know identifying evil or perhaps
terminating a target
you've got to understand what those
intentions and motivations are like and
by the way i almost forgot to mention
this all these years we've known each
other i had no idea your feelings about
cats yes no i'm now i'm sad we just we
just got another rescue cat that's two
two cats oh you're turning into a little
old lady i'm one shy
but we also have several dogs and a
hamster yeah have you got the housecoat
yet
well you as if you haven't seen my house
yeah yeah yeah yeah so we don't have
matching house coats so you're um you're
being very evasive yeah i am
you know you stopped killing people
years ago i hope mike baker so you can
answer this question do you believe that
evil exists
absolutely sure yeah but i do think that
there's
oftentimes we're quick to use the phrase
i think your monologue was spot on i
think
we're very quick to throw that out there
right because words don't really mean
anything anymore right i mean it's just
uh it's it's bizarre how everything's
the worst i've ever seen everything's
the most horrible situation i've ever
seen that's the most evil person i've
ever seen i mean look how quickly we we
refer to people as nazis nowadays yes
and there used to be a firewall there
because
people had a long enough memory and it
was in recent enough history that they
understood what the evil of that was and
so now we're we're kind of off the
plantation but yes evil does exist uh
but more often than not uh you won't see
it coming yeah good point you know greg
i'm sorry that you weren't able to wash
the bloodstains out of your shirt
but uh
[Laughter]
you know do you uh do you think we
weaken the word by using it so much
especially in conversation yeah of
course we do i mean look you know to to
mike's point about evil uh being the
nazis and hitler
it just it's a shortcut to shut people
down to go ad hominem and not have civil
discourse so
you know sticks and stones it's
playground stuff we should be able to
speak about the issues and um and talk
about you know our differences and come
to some kind of
um agreement that cats shouldn't be in
your house or my house and only mike's
house yes could you just could you just
quickly explain to the audience what ad
hominem means
random without reason you take the
argument not the person i understood it
i just didn't think oh okay wait a
second are you insulting my audience
wow that's the first time you've ever
insulted the audience well look at them
whoa
i challenged
i just want to say that i think you're
all very smart and attractive
you know what i realized if you know
what this show needs we need a corner
like a what do you call it where a
timeout space
you would never get through the
monologue
but what would we know but a guest has
to go and sit like over there for one
second
a little time you need a penalty box you
gave me an idea in spite of yourself um
cat are you evil
no no
what is evil
yeah i mean i guess evil is is a bad
evil person right like hitler is evil
uh i just when you throw the word around
though like if you're gonna be nice to
people you're gonna get more out of them
which is why the audience is gonna like
me more because i said they were
good-looking
and you called them dumb
which is why like if anyone ever
abducted me most people like scream but
what i would do is be like why you
picked me
what did you like about me that you
didn't like about all the other girls
and then like maybe we just hang out no
no no you become very clingy
the thing is you know tyrus it's so
funny because we watch so much video uh
in our lives of like iran shouting death
to america oh my god they hate us but
we've we kind of been doing that
ourselves well we're some we're all evil
in somebody's story right yes we're all
the bad guys it's it's a mental
construct but like
uh to to say
the word evil doesn't mean anything
anymore because
now it's we it's more about an arrogant
ignorance that's more of a problem than
evil i'm so important
i'm so right with no wisdom or backing
at all that anyone who says anything
against me or challenged me is evil so
therefore i don't have to improve myself
i don't have to listen to that i have to
take advice because i know so that's the
word evil
doesn't even used to say it and everyone
would stop like if we were in a
restaurant somewhere and there was an
argument broke out and for some reason i
would
call my
wife evil for not letting me have
dessert they'd be like oh my gosh she
must be horrible now it's like it's just
it's a comma it's like racist
nazi usually you call somebody a nazi
they had to earn it yeah because that
bar was set pretty high i mean it was
you know the rotten thing to do but it's
it's mellowed out because we've become
such a first problem
actual nazis must be like what the [ __ ]
i was just saying because it was a
pretty rotten thing to do
oh and by the way audience i'm taking
you all out for drinks after
that i am holding you to that
i am don't let him go when the show ends
he's going to take off his mic and he's
going to try to run out
gene you block the door
there's a great place oh he's going to
kill gene yeah there's a place across
the street called longacre you should be
over there by like 8 o'clock okay it's a
deal with your wallet open
not your pants
terrible if he doesn't show up he's just
being evil yes
it's the sort of thing a nazi would do
exactly exactly hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else